[Music]  oh hi good to see you hi still work at  the orphanage going oh great great you  know the children they're so blessed but  how's that nonprofit you started it's  been fantastic we're building 10 new  homes to see here for the victims 10  homes dog our mutton today you are such  an inspiration  thank you so much I mean well I guess  I'm going out by  Hey  [Applause]  [Music]  [Music]  what just happened  oh no that's gross okay great  what is that there we go now we're never  good  no we're not thinking out of the big  this pinch it'll go away it's so quiet  out  huh it's been like this all day  I mean it is everything I know funding  oh so good to see you action  Oh  Thanks  [Music]